I found your headshot oh no a number of
years ago put this that may be the worst
here's what's wrong about that other
than everything yeah but were you on the
cast of certain alive you'd listen you
wrote it you just buy the shirt let me
tell you you or a writer on SNL yeah so
they still talk about the Belushi the
Pardo years they talk about all the
crazy shirt on I don't know why am I
wearing Sally Jessy Raphael glasses I
don't know why am I wearing ester wash
jeans why do I have a mullet like I'm a
goalie yeah look at my shoes everything
about that says look at me I'm an
I like that you're sitting on
that little piece of carpet right
everything about is bad listen you're
here with me now and everything's good
do you work out does that feel soft now
listen I don't Toledo lower-body
I got it I'll get down there soon Oh
you